the alleged murder of a Colorado mother
are looking into a new lead hundreds of
miles away sources tell CBS News that
officials are investigating an Idaho
woman for her possible role in Kelsey
Barrett's disappearance in November
Bharath fiance Patrick Frazee is charged
with her murder
Niki batiste is following the
investigation Nikki good morning good
morning we're not releasing the name of
the Idaho woman police are looking into
since she hasn't been charged but police
believe she may have helped Patrick
Frazee cover up the alleged murder
details of their relationship are
unclear but they reportedly knew each
other for years a 32 year old nurse from
Twin Falls Idaho may have helped Patrick
Frazee cover up the alleged murder of
his fiancee Kelsey Bharath by disposing
of Bharath cell phone investigators
believe Frazee a blacksmith murdered the
29 year old flight instructor around
thanksgiving day in her colorado home
the engaged couple did not live together
but have a one-year-old daughter Kaylee
Bharath was last seen on this store
surveillance video with her baby the day
she vanished three days later police say
Bharath cell phone pinged nearly 600
miles away in gooding Idaho several
texts were sent from the phone including
one to her employer saying she would be
away for a week and another to Frazee
district attorney dan Mae says
investigators do not believe Frazee
acted alone he's charged with five
counts including two counts of first
degree murder we filed under two
theories one is de libération murder and
the other is felony murder we also have
three separate counts of solicitation so
far no other suspects have been named
embarrass body has not been found
a separate legal battle is brewing over
custody of Caylee Frazee walked into a
Colorado courthouse Thursday as his
mother fights Barrett's parents for
custody of their granddaughter
we spoke with Barriss mother Cheryl last
month when did you last see her October
2 kelsey ever at any point mentioned she
was in fear of her safety no Barrett's
parents have temporary parental rights
that are caring for Caylee at their
Idaho home a hearing is scheduled today
over the release of Frazee's arrest
warrant a warrant affidavit which
prosecutors have sealed citing an
ongoing investigation I know you've been
following this case from the beginning
there's got to be some digital footprint
probably from whoever his accomplice was
there's a preliminary hearing January
29th world will hear some evidence all
right Mickey thank you